it's great to welcome back to the
program chris had naggy the founder and
ceo of social engineer llc and also an
adjunct professor of social engineering
for the university of arizona also
author of the book human hacking win
friends influence people and leave them
better off for having met you chris
always great to talk to you oh great to
talk to you too again david so many
might recognize win friends and
influence people to reference reference
to the great dale carnegie book
sort of really should be it's important
reading i feel like for for everybody it
contains a lot of interesting
information
what is the connection between the title
of your book and uh the dale carnegie
book so i i love that book right i
really do and it and like you said i
think it should be required reading in
school because it has so many great
principles in it but if some of us don't
know it was written in in the 1930s
right so it's a it's a really old book
and i i it's just like an
a homage to carnegie and saying hey i i
have some new principles that we can use
some new techniques for the modern era
that are all taken from from my work as
a social engineer and
let's see how we could keep that same
principle he
being kind to people really getting to
know them learning how to communicate
but bring it to the 21st century so it's
really an ode to him and in the past you
and i have talked about different ways
in which social engineering can be used
i guess i would say for bad in the sense
of used to scam people
use to defeat physical security and you
work in testing physical security and
cyber security at different companies
etc um but there's also sort of like
another side to social engineering which
is simply like better understanding how
to get along with people how to relate
to people etc there's a totally there's
a flip side to it there is and it was
only after i was doing that part the
security part for about a decade that i
said i wonder what happens if i just use
the same thing i did to break in this
building but do it when i'm at the
checkout line or if i'm just waiting for
coffee or i'm at a store and somebody's
angry can i defuse that situation and i
just started trying these things little
by little and without manipulating
people without having to force someone
into doing something they didn't want to
do i found that you can communicate with
people and get almost anything you want
just by being nice kind and empathetic
and that's how this book came about i
i've said to people on on my show before
and in other circumstances that one of
the experiences that most sort of
leveled up my ability to build rapport
and relate to people
was working in sales at the now defunct
uh electronics chain circuit city where
i started when i was 16 years old and
you had all sorts of different people
coming in many already angry because of
some bad experience they had you know um
uh people who want to they don't know
whether you can actually help them
figure out what laptop to buy for their
kid or whatever the case may be
it's an incredibly valuable skill to
have to know how to very quickly relate
to people and build rapport can you talk
about sort of some of the principles and
again we're not talking about
manipulating people we're just talking
about relating to people yeah and i
think that's a really important point
that last point you brought up because
that's why at the very end of that title
i put and leave them feeling better for
having met you right because the the
mission is yeah you can go out and use
these principles for bad you can't and
you can manipulate people you can get
them to do things they don't want to do
but if you leave that one thought in
your head which is anything i do right
now i'm going to make sure you feel
better when we're done interacting that
you're going to go man that was a great
conversation i like that guy right if i
do that then i'm not going to manipulate
you right so let's just think of robert
cialdini's principles of influence we
could take one right let's use liking
viking is an easy one right so he makes
this statement that people like people
who are like them
and people like people who like them so
i can fake it and i can be all nice to
you and smiley but then later on you
hear me go oh man i really hate that guy
and now you feel bad you don't feel good
so then you're like oh he manipulated me
he got me to do something he didn't even
like me that's not cool or i can learn
to say i'm going to pick something out
about this person i don't know and i'm
going to be interested in them and i
really am and i'm going to want to know
more about you and you're going to tell
me about that now later on you're going
to think man i met this great guy at
that coffee shop and we had an amazing
conversation for complete strangers and
it's that simple where you could use
that same principle you can manipulate
someone or you can change the way you
communicate and you can influence
someone and and really communicate in a
more holistic way building rapport and
making friends that may be short-term or
long-term but either way you you walk
away with a an amazing interaction with
a complete stranger now i think that
there are many i know in my audience but
out there in the general public who they
hear this conversation or they read dale
carnegie's book and they say
i'm an introvert this stuff doesn't work
for me this is horrifying this actually
this is the these are the last types of
things that i want to be doing and we do
see actually that in ceos for example
introversion is underrepresented
relative to the general population
there's a question right as to
sort of that
what about that what about the fact that
for a lot of people this entire way of
thinking about relating to others is is
just very unappetizing yeah that's
that's an awesome question because my
ceo at social engineer he is a massive
introvert
and uh we always talk about this because
he's he's one of the leading social
engineers and you know he goes and
breaks in the buildings communicates
with people does all this stuff
we we always talk about okay how do you
do this how do you get there so the
first step is you have to as an
introvert you have to have a desire to
change
right and and you really do it has to be
from you it can't be because i tell you
to do it or you know they hear something
on a show that has to be like okay look
i just want to try something new because
it's that desire to step out of your
comfort zone that is the first step now
where i see a lot of people who are
introverts fail is they hear this
conversation they go okay i'm going to
go out and do it and they pick the whole
thing right i'm going to go out and do
this whole thing and now it's scary
maybe they fail a little and then they
go i knew i couldn't do it don't do that
pick one thing say hey today when i go
into starbucks i'm gonna get one
person's first name that's it start
small so i'm gonna get one person's
first name so now i'm standing in line
and you're in front of me and i'm an
introvert and i go hey is that the new
iphone you know i was thinking of
upgrading do you like that you know is
it good do you have any problems with it
and they'll they'll talk your ear off
and then you go man thanks hey i'm chris
you shake my hand go i am dave great now
we could part ways and i accomplished
that one goal i asked you a question i
got your first name now next time say
now i'm going to get someone's full name
right and you give yourself little
incremental steps instead of saying i'm
going to go do this whole thing and what
you'll find is eventually it will get
easier and easier but if you're not
naturally a person who likes to just go
out and talk to strangers then don't
throw yourself in the deep end right you
start swimming you stay where you can
stand still so now do it little the flip
side of this and again in thinking about
your expertise and
fishing and fishing and you know all
these different things is
sometimes um the reason people get
sucked into scams
is because the person who's scamming
them
has exactly the skills that you're
talking about right they're they're hey
that was a great experience i ended up
feeling good about that i like this
person they seem trustworthy so what
about the other side which is being
equipped to protect yourself from people
who may do exactly the things you're
saying but with with uh
with subterfuge so to speak no that's
that's an awesome question so here's
what i tell people because
uh sometimes i'll hear people give
suggestions for protection but they they
make us not human
and we can't do that we can't i mean
first of all we can't
you can't control your emotional output
it's you're you're a person so if if you
feel fear or if you feel happy or if you
see someone that you think is attractive
your body is going to react in a way and
you're not going to be able to control
it right right so what i tell people is
to if you could stay self-aware in a
conversation
and when i start to feel emotional about
something whatever that emotion is happy
fear sadness whatever to analyze quickly
is what i'm being asked to do next
dangerous or not right so let's say i'm
the introvert standing in line with my
brand new iphone yeah you come up behind
me and you're the introvert that's going
to have a talk with me
and you say hey is that the brand new
iphone like i was thinking of upgrading
and i don't really want to talk to you
but i'm now self-aware and i go why
would he ask me that but you said oh
he's going to try to upgrade okay well
what you're asking me is not anything
dangerous so i go yeah this is the new
iphone
and now if you said hey can i hold it
can i see it
now i don't know i feel a little weird
why is a stranger asking me to hand you
my phone so i'm like well i don't really
feel comfortable with that with covid
and everything sorry but you know i'll
show it to you
now i i could be self-aware with that
and say you know i don't feel
comfortable with that level of
interaction but you're just asking me
about my phone you're not asking me for
my phone number or credit cards or
anything then i can continue that
conversation so it's a matter of staying
self-aware during the conversation to
make sure you don't give anything out
that could put you in danger and that's
exactly i i feel like and i'm curious to
see what you think that's exactly what
the this good scammer social engine
engineer is probably good at which is
maybe even delaying the asks that raise
red flags until enough trust has been
built where the mark would say i don't
know it's been an hour it i've known
this person for a month and it's all
been fine so and and maybe that's where
the difficulty comes with the more
sophisticated scams
true and you know i just read a story it
was about a couple months ago this poor
widowed woman lost 114 thousand dollars
in a romance scam it didn't happen
overnight you know they were quote
unquote dating online and this guy took
her for a couple thousand five thousand
and ten thousand and incrementally got
more and more and more uh a year or so
into it she's out a hundred and fourteen
thousand dollars this poor woman um yeah
so you're right it's it's they they
build the relationship because the
principle of influences that we talk
about before from chaldini or rapport um
you will give more to someone who you
trust more right so they can't come up
to you and say hey dave give me 114k and
you're like heck no man but if all of a
sudden we're best friends you know we're
we're we're like blood brothers and you
trust me with everything well maybe
maybe now you would part with that if i
really need it and you have it
so
they they wait to build that
relationship to do the ask hey to talk
about something from the last sort of
year and a half related to all of this
what are we seeing in terms of uh
scamming and fishing etc related to
covid i mean the one thing i've seen is
calls sort of like the social security
calls but related to the covet stimulus
we were seeing that for a little while
but that's
it's sort of just a version of something
we've seen before what else are we
seeing so because
this is such a global thing
normally when we see some kind of
catastrophe it's very localized like a
you know a flood in louisiana or the
earthquake in haiti or something like
that where you go okay this is localized
and then they attack that group of
people
this is not this is global so what we're
seeing is that these attacks are
happening all over to everyone and
they're very fear-based so see you know
click here to download this app to see
who has covet in your area that's a big
one they want to take over your phone uh
emails coming from your work saying hey
we need you to install this program to
work from home
right then you like the phone calls
where this is a huge thing think about
it people working in the office now you
got mom dad and two kids all trying to
find a place at home to work so you're
working from your bedroom your kitchen
table somewhere else and you're working
more than you ever were before now you
get a call someone that says they're
from i.t hey listen we've got to put a
patch on your machine so you can connect
to the vpns while you're you know at
home and people will install programs
and this is how we're seeing major
breaches occur phone email and sms have
gone through the roof and now you add to
that that verizon t-mobile and att have
all been breached in the last 12 months
your phone number's out there my phone
number is out there this is why we're
seeing an increase in phone calls and
text messages all over is there any um
are are there blanket recommendations
that
take people out of having to make sort
of like one-on-one decisions as
frequently like for example i no longer
pick up my phone at all unless i know
exactly who's calling me and it's for a
bunch of different reasons including
that people who don't like me have found
my phone number yeah but but also
because overwhelmingly if i don't
recognize the number if it's a real call
they're going to leave a voicemail yes
and if it's not i never hear back so
like that would be one thing that i do
are there other blanket things everybody
can just make regular practices yeah uh
these will seem a little technical but i
will say them just because i think
that's a very important topic first is i
encourage everyone to use a password
manager
because the the issue with the phone
calls and stuff is eventually we're
going to answer a call or we may fall
for something
but if we use a password manager then we
don't have the same password on every
website yeah and they're easy to change
and control but even if you do that the
next thing is vitally important and
that's to use multi-factor
authentication on everything that allows
you and if you have a choice don't use
the one that sends you a text message
use the one that lets you use an app you
know like duo or authy or microsoft
authenticate or something like that
because that they need to have access to
your physical phone in order to get that
and if they have that you already have
bigger problems right so those two
things alone and there's a ton of others
but those two things alone could save so
many people
and then the third thing i'll say and
this is something that we can do for
free in america um which is you could
put a freeze on your credit with all
three major credit bureaus right and you
can do that you don't have to pay a
service it's easy it takes five minutes
and you can unfreeze it in five minutes
and i suggest everyone do that because
if you have a password manager
multi-factor authentication and your
your account is locked
people even if they steal your data
they're not going to be able to use it
so that keeps you from having to worry
boy did i just mess up did i give
someone the wrong thing and and it can
keep you relative nothing will keep you
hacker proof but it could keep you
relatively safe now in terms of just the
incoming phone calls
is there
sometimes you get legit phone calls
because there really has been you know
your credit card calls because there's a
charge they want to confirm or
i don't know if banks really call people
frequently my bank doesn't call me but
i'm guessing banks make phone calls
sometimes for real so is there some
overarching principle that can be
applied to any incoming phone call to
prevent falling even if it's one out of
a thousand that you fall for yeah
so i i do exactly what you said which is
i let them go to voicemail even if it
looks legit or if i do pick it up and
let's just say it's my bank and they go
hey this is your bank we have some weird
charges we need to verify yeah i say hey
i can't talk right now i'll call you
back i do not call the number on the
phone i take my card out of my wallet i
call the toll-free number and i say hey
someone just called me from the bank
saying there are some weird charges i
need to verify right because i know that
i'm talking to the real bank because i
called you
but when you call me i don't know and if
they just start trying to verify
information heck man with some of these
breaches they have all of that so they
can sound super legit sure you know so i
just you and don't ever call a number
they give you just yesterday i had a a
friend of mine who got a call someone
saying they're from amazon and they were
helping them try to complete a purchase
on the account and they were they needed
them to install a program they didn't
fall for it but they gave him a number
and he called the number back and
someone picked up oh amazon how can we
help you right so they even have people
answering the phone
with the you know the numbers that
they're giving out so you can't trust it
if they give it to you but if you call a
legitimate number then you can trust it
another one i've seen gotten recently is
i'll get an email saying
hey um we just charged you 40 bucks
for the something you ordered and of
course you go i didn't order that i got
to go and get a refund so then you look
at the info on the email and of course
if you called my guess is they would say
oh yeah what was the credit card number
you put it and and then you're off to
the races yeah and and if you think
about that sounds so legitimate right
because if i call into an actual vendor
like if i call my bank right now they're
going to say please verify the account
you're calling about right they're not
going to give me the account
they're going to ask me to verify it so
i'm going to legitimately give them my
account number sure which could be my
credit card so if i call what i think is
my bank and they go hey to look you up
we need to verify your identity i need
your full name your account number your
social security that sounds all
legitimate right so people will give it
over and what they don't know is that if
you didn't call if you didn't initiate
that call there's no way for you to
verify that you're speaking to the
actual company the actual person right
right so i always say the best practices
you have to initiate the call um you
know unless there's some solid proof
like you know you're standing you're
you're on the phone and they're
verifying with you enough that you feel
comfortable with that or they're not
asking you for personal details i still
really just i'd rather just pick up the
phone and call them back agreed agreed
we've been speaking with chris had naggy
founder and ceo of social engineer llc
the book is human hacking when friends
influence people and leave them better
off for having met you chris always
appreciate your time thanks david